cette longue baptise c'est la maison
hantée de vailhauquès un village situé à
quelques kilomètres de montpellier
depuis trois mois la famille boudon un
couple et son fils est réveillé
pratiquement chaque pluie toujours entre
23h et 1h du matin par des coups parfois
sur parfois violents qui se répercute
dans les murs de la maison je tenterai
jouer seul très sourd lorsque l'eau ce
qu'ils arrivent mais lorsqu'il se trouve
à proximité de votre appartement si on
peut dire ici c'est très fort j'ai
l'impression que le poids d'une balcon
lâchait qui tombe et qui retombait 10ème
tome qui dont le géologue le bruit vient
du sol
mais ce n'est pas un bruit de la terre 4
parapsychologue il invoque la psycho qui
neige autrement dit une action de la
pensée sur la matière la psycho sida est
forcément associée à un trouble affectif
au vendredi dernier quand les géologues
sont allés dans le puits et qu'ils ont
volontairement frappé contre les parois
du puits
les bidons sont les seuls à 20
témoignages d'avoir entendu quelque
chose
en attendant les conclusions de ces
spécialistes la famille boudon continue
à supporter ses mauvais coups venus
d'ailleurs mais pour le seul esprit ne
permet plus de résoudre les énigmes
on entend s'adresser directement au
saint-esprit c'est pourquoi un exorciste
doit venir visiter la maison au cours de
la semaine
en grande-bretagne forcément des
histoires de fantômes encore dans le
château d'hampton court tho nord de
londres des images mystérieuses prises
par une caméra de surveillance de
l'ancienne demeure du roi henri 8
relance le débat sur le spectre qui
entraient les lieux jérôme soûlard
le château de grandson cordes c'est l'un
des joyaux de la couronne britannique au
centre ce dimanche d'une polémique
délicieusement brut tous les châteaux
anglais ont leurs fantômes mais cette
fois-ci paraît-il c'est différent à
quelqu'un ou quelque chose qui apparaît
dans une clinique sont ils ouvrent une
porte puis une autre et les referme
c'est vraiment quelque chose d'étrange
filmée par une caméra de surveillance
une silhouette inquiétante d'un mètre
quatre-vingt vêtu d'une longue tunique
gris-beige même pour un gardien du
château britannique
cela fait froid dans le dos quand je
fais ma ronde le soir autour du château
je ressens chaque fois comme un courant
d'air froid cela fait peur alors je pars
en courant le plus sérieusement du monde
la presse britannique annonce déjà le
retour d'henry huit anciens
propriétaires des lieux vrai fantôme aux
gags intéresser aujourd'hui des dizaines
de touristes affluent au château aimé
leur ticket content en ces temps de
restriction pour la couronne britannique
un vrai faux fantômes qui pourrait
rapporter gros au château du anton
à
le mauvais esprit at il pris pour cible
cette modeste demeure d'une famille
belge la sphère fait grand bruit outre
quiévrain
car derrière ces murs que l'on ne
franchit plus des phénomènes surnaturels
auraient été observés tous voulaient en
hauteur des couteaux tout au lond
légèrement ce que débutait la table je
veux en fait le mauvais esprit se
seraient déchaînés depuis l'arrivée dans
la maison de ce jeune homme fiancée de
la fille du propriétaire
c'est lui qui attirera les ondes
négatives d'après leurs ados résiste au
moins goûter ou envoûtés on me dirige la
parentèle c'est comme ça tous les objets
l'histoire prêterait à rire si la
maréchaussée belge n'avait été à son
tour confronté à l'irrationnel neuf
gendarmes appelés sur les lieux ont été
témoins de vols d'objets identifiés
un livre qui traversait une pièce un
morceau de marbre qui s'envolait ou
encore un matelas en lévitation
ce sont des gendarmes qui travaillent
habituellement bien et donc ne sont pas
sensibles à des influences particulières
dans ce cadre là ce qui nous ont vus sur
place au moins ces quelques objets qui
se sont déplacés dans l'air sans
explication apparente que diable se
passe-t-il donc dans cette maison les
esprits fragiles parle de magie noire
les experts de champs magnétiques
on s'interroge sur les effets d'une
ligne haute tension ou encore sur ceux
de la source qui coule sous la maison
y at il eu un phénomène d'hallucinations
collectives ou at-on affaire un
illusionniste chevronnés autant de
questions qui hantent l'esprit des gens
de la région
les bruits que vous venez d'entendre ont
été enregistrés la nuit dernière dans la
cité des neuf fontaines a bavé depuis
deux semaines cette cité vibre sous les
coups tous les soirs on y entend des
bruits étranges comme si quelqu'un
donner des coups de bélier dans les murs
au départ ça a été le bruit au garage la
porte puis après la porte d'entrée bombe
à mon mari s'est mis derrière le garage
pour voir s'il est vraiment pas
plaisantins ou pas de quoi ça venait et
puis bon ben on a bien vu qu'il y avait
personne qui frappe et poussa gros bruit
mais ça fait boum âme et aux parfums et
la dame jeudi la dame qui était dans la
salle de bain tout a tremblé
il y à bien des sont sourds d'intensité
variable qui reviennent à intervalles
irréguliers et qui ne laisse aucune
trace sur les murs ou des pages en
rigoler à venir heureusement maintenant
ce qui changeait du tout c'est concret
dans une chambre voulez vous avez fait
appel à me procurer au curé lui aussi
décidé avec un autre exercice gaz de
france à vérifier les canalisations sans
succès ses bruits n'ont toujours pas
d'explication logique
certains dans le quartier font
simplement remarquer que tout a commencé
avec l'arrivée des nièces de la
propriétaire
mais on imagine mal de filles est donné
des coups de masse dans les murs sans se
faire remarquer
et vous croyez vous aux fantômes au pays
de galles les propriétaires d'un vieux
manoir ont trouvé le filon pour
restaurer leur propriété ils organisent
régulièrement des chasse aux zombies
spectre et autres ectoplasme au pays de
galles le reportage de yann fossurier et
olivier palomino c'est une vieille
demeure du xviie siècle perdu dans la
campagne galloise
si on en croit le folklore local le
manoir de plastique serait hanté par des
fantômes
depuis plus de 200 ans cette mystérieuse
bâtisse a été restauré il ya une
vingtaine d'années la propriétaire et
accueille aujourd'hui des amateurs de
paranormal venus de toute la
grande-bretagne des chasseurs
d'ectoplasmes comme china et ses amis
faites attention c'est très sombre et si
ils ont formé un club et visitent
régulièrement ce manoir les week-ends la
nuit de préférence
ils recherchent inlassablement des
indices qui confirmeraient la présence
de fantômes
bardé d'instruments électroniques il
mesure les ondes électromagnétiques et
surveille les variations de température
j'ai relevé des fluctuations importantes
mon thermomètre indique et 18° et demi
dans cet endroit reculé laissant du ss a
besoin de remonter à 22 avec leur
appareil photo équipé de lasers et de
lampes à infrarouge
dv paul pense avoir saisi quelque chose
ce soir dans ce couloir
c'est ce cliché qui a retenu mon
attention car je me demande encore ce
qui a pu causer cette sorte de halo
inhabituel je n'avais jamais vu quelque
chose comme ça avant
plusieurs visiteurs disent avoir aperçu
dans ce manoir les spectres de deux
enfants est celui d'une jeune femme tous
comme faute à les gêner montrez-vous
jamais comme ça xin haï christine entre
en méditation
elle tente d'établir un contact avec ses
esprits qui entrait le manoir sous le
regard dubitatif de ce jeune couple qui
les a accompagné ce soir je suis plutôt
sceptique mais on ressent vraiment
quelque chose de spécial ici c'est
excitant
ces chasseurs de fantômes accepte qu'on
les suive la nuit dans le manoir de
plasteig à condition de payer 60 euros a
donc anciens ce manoir a besoin d'argent
pour être maintenu en l'état
alors quand nous organisons des visites
ici l'argent collecté est entièrement
reversé à la première
la propriétaire des lieux est une femme
discrète elle n'apparaît jamais lors de
ces safaris du paranormal
elle dit ne pas croire aux fantômes
tapi dans l'ombre la dame blanche attend
peut-être au détour du virage on l'a
signalé aux quatre coins de la france
mais elle est ici chez elle
les gorges sont infestés de mauvaise
femme sur cette falaise par exemple des
faits attire les passes en riant et en
chantant pour mieux les précipiter au
fond du gouffre c'est cruel mais elle
aime ça jusqu'au siècle dernier les gens
les voyageurs des nausées porte à ce
temple du fier parce que c'était plein
d'histoires mystérieuses plein de bruit
peut-être ont-ils croisé mathilde depuis
sa mort ou xiiie siècle l ontt les
youyous et île de lamu dit fillon plus
légère que son père unis en l'isolant du
monde
il faut s'arrêter au bon endroit pour
discerner de la route les restes de sa
demeure un peu folle elle rançonnaient
avec ses gardes les passants égarés elle
avait des stations qui les arrêtaient et
qu'il dépouille à 2 to qui les laissait
du ch à bord du chemin tout elle
accumulait les trésors des présentes
pour ton s'est jamais servi d'ailleurs
les morte avec
elle aurait caché son butin dans une
grotte mais laquelle on ne sait pas ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'on a croisé encore
de temps en temps la dame blanche
il paraît que c'est impressionnant quand
elle surgit et celle qui hier sur la
route est la plus dangereuse des dames
blanches
qui pourrait imaginer que l'aimer
cela paraît aberrant à notre époque
pourtant les témoignages affluent à ce
sujet bruits étranges dans certaines
maisons par effrayant candeur curieuse
présence invisible quand je descends de
là haut j'ai l'impression que quelqu'un
qui me suit derrière mon dos et l'assise
autour de la table on entend du marché
l'a donc in après ya eu des bruits des
bruits bizarres mais ça conscient taper
dans les murs de cet esprit donc vous le
voyez vous moi je le vois sous forme de
masque pudique gazeuse pas comme un
nuage et donc le rôle c'est de chasser
l'esprit je me met à tousser violemment
je perds la voix je peux même resté
bloqué d'une jambe
enfin plus la force négative enfin des
fastes est importante plus le court
circuit et violent je m'en sers de sel
béni et donc je le
je jette le sel en direction de la
présence de l'esprit et j'arrive à le
neutraliser avec un magnétisme quand la
force négative est neutralisée je
ressens une grande décontraction et
m'avoir vient maintenant j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ont encore des
forces négatives dans la courge et
non
un village comme il en existe tant
d'autres en france un village tranquille
où les jours s'écoulent paisible jusqu'à
ce que des phénomènes mystérieux s'y
produisent dans une habitation le linge
les meubles se consume sans que l'on
puisse encore apporter une quelconque
explication à cela
pour éviter que le feu ne se propage des
tours de garde sont organisées par la
population la nuit notamment comme cette
nuit là la douzième depuis les premiers
feux tous les habitants de ce héros y
participer si parfois on est inquiet
plutôt troublée par ce qui se passe on
ne le montre pas et on ne veut pas y
penser mais quand même assez rond on a
fait venir un prêtre exorciste pourquoi
pas semblé ton dire dans le village de
toute façon cela ne peut pas faire de
mal
il est resté longtemps dans la maison il
a conseillé de brûler les étapes dont en
plumes c'est là que se niche le mal
généralement mais la nuit suivante
un nouveau feu se déclarait c'est à
propos de michel la jeune fille qui vit
depuis six ans chez les lahore que les
rumeurs les plus folles ont circulé
parce que c'est la seule personne de la
famille dont les vêtements brûlés sur l
on a commencé à la regarder de travers à
la désigner du doigt le phénomène
paranormal et s'il s'agit d'un phénomène
paranormal celui ci est d'un ordre tout
nouveau interrogé au téléphone
l'exercice du diocèse de paris le père
ghislain qui s'est vu soumettre des
milliers de cas qu oscar hier nous a
répondu que sans avoir eu à connaître
personnellement de cette affaire il
estimait que les faits ne l'état n'est
nullement